if you have a severe problem with the
aortic valve in your heart your doctor
May recommend a transcatheter aortic
valve implantation or Tavi it's also
known as transcatheter aortic valve
replacement or tover
your aortic valve is one of the four
valves in your heart it lies between
your left ventricle or lower left
chamber and the large blood vessel
supplying oxygen-rich blood to your body
called the aorta
when your left ventricle contract during
each heartbeat it pushes blood through
three flexible cup like leaflets that
make up your aortic valve
when your left ventricle relaxes your
aortic valve closes to prevent blood
from flowing back into your left
ventricle
as you get older your aortic valve May
develop deposits of calcium that cause
your leaflets to get thicker and less
flexible
in this condition your leaflets may not
open fully
this condition called calcific aortic
valve stenosis creates a narrowed
opening that reduces the amount of blood
flowing into your aorta and out to your
body
as a result the wall of your left
ventricle thickens because it has to
work harder to pump blood through the
narrowed valve opening
at the beginning of your procedure your
doctor will make a small incision in
your groin
after creating an opening in a blood
vessel called the femoral artery
your doctor will insert a flexible tube
called an introducer sheath
through the sheath your doctor will
insert a flexible guide wire into your
femoral artery
the guide wire will be passed through
your femoral artery
all the way up to your aorta
then the guide wire will be pushed
through the opening in your aortic valve
and into your left ventricle
your doctor will use the guide wire to
pass a flexible tube called a catheter
through your aortic valve
a balloon on the tip of the catheter
will be inflated to widen the opening in
your aortic valve to push the valve
leaflets to the sides
after deflating the balloon your doctor
will remove the catheter
the replacement valve consists of a
tissue valve surrounded by a wire mesh
called a stent
the replacement valve will be compressed
and placed on the tip of another
catheter
this catheter will be inserted through
your aortic valve
when the catheter reaches the opening in
your aortic valve your doctor will
inflate a balloon underneath the
replacement valve to expand it and the
stent
after placement of the new aortic valve
your doctor will deflate the balloon
the stent will support and secure the
replacement valve in place
the catheter and guide wire will be
removed
at the end of the procedure the
introducer sheath in your groin will be
removed and your skin incision will be
closed
you will have another incision on the
other side of your groin through which
instruments were inserted to monitor
your heart during the procedure this
skin incision will also be closed
to find out more about transcatheter
aortic valve implantation talk to your
Healthcare practitioner